you have a new character sometimes uh
really bad things
stick with people i have no idea why
this was just a notion of
uh like i like to do like bad stand-ups
this guy's name
red red neckie the redneck comedian okay
and the jokes are intentionally terrible
and he has a catchphrase so see if it
amuses you i don't know
intentionally bad comedy um this is my
second to last show
and you're trying [ __ ] out
on a piece of paper
well this this looks like a suicide note
you rip it out
i played this theater a few times and i
came out like look at this bit look at
that bit
and it never really worked so i
discovered that the largo theater
yeah experimental theater yes but i
saved it i was gonna work this out
someplace really uh you know a small
club stuff but i thought let's do it on
one of conan's final show
so cause i wanna just try [ __ ] out
this is red rednecky red red neckie the
redneck comedian intentionally bad you
ever crap
so big you don't know gonna go down that
turlet come and get some
crazy is that his catchphrase come and
get come and get some
i met my sister only because mama turned
me down
coma get something
this is scaring me because this would do
very well in some places
it surprisingly does well i asked my
mama what's for dinner she says roadkill
i said what kind she says i gotta take a
drive come and get some
grandpa invented the phrase dollars to
donuts every time i got a buck he bought
a donut he died at 37. come and get some
you know you need to hear him yeah this
one's a little emotional my mama asked
me what's your dream read i said living
in a shack and drinking beer all day she
said don't dream too big cause you
always end up disappointed
come again
[Laughter]
a little songs i'm coming get some
humming it's um
i want to say until you started trying
[ __ ] out it was an honor
having you here i was trying out the
whole time
you are i met you i i don't know i was
24 years old
24 years old i i you were the funniest
person
uh then and still to this day you make
me laugh
so hard and you're a brilliant man and
you're a very nice guy and you coming on
my show
all these times over the years if you
told me in 88 when i first met you
it's amazing someday conan you'll have a
show and this guy will come on and he'll
waste time on your second to last show
that's good that wasn't boring then you
know you saw someone
but let me come right back at you you uh
when you started and then you were a
writer primarily on the show
and i kept hearing conan's the funniest
guy in the writers room
you know but then i'd be around you and
you'd be a little shy i was quiet around
uh talent yeah i would do little voices
come on you know
and then eventually you became the
funniest guy in america
well i wouldn't say that
i'll take nine i've been i'm happy to be
nine well
no no one no one's no one in
in in the last 30 years has done this
much comedy that's this good i don't
think
it's volume and i mean uh i didn't know
we get this serious but really i mean
there's only as funny as you there's no
funnier than you
and you and andy no one has a sidekick
you know relationship like
this yeah because andy will just lay you
out with the subtlest things out of
nowhere yeah
and conan will be very sweet as pie and
then explode into this comedy part
and this nice audience is seeing that
you know this this thing we've had
together all these years and we've
become really really good friends in
life we really have
and uh i love you and i thank you so
much for being here
and uh uh let's talk to our we have we
share our therapist
we share a therapist but not that's not
a joke not at the same time
but most of my sessions are about my
relationship with conan yeah yeah
and i try to get him and i uh every now
and then i'll be like dana uh
she'll be like she'll she will i won't
give her name but she will say like
how's it going i'll be like well
you know doing a little better than dana
i'm probably not supposed to disclose
that but i think it's hilarious that you
and i have the same therapist
howard stern i told him and he was very
upset about that oh that's just wrong
you should have your own therapist you
know that's that's
terrible oh she's fantastic she is
fantastic you're fantastic i'm fantastic
everybody
you